THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BREAKING
NEWS, OPENING MONOLOGUE.
TONIGHT, JUDGE BRETT KAVANAUGH
IS FIGHTING BACK AND STANDING UP
FOR HIS GOOD NAME AND HIS
REPUTATION, AND HE IS DEMANDING
A FAIR PROCESS.
HE SAYS HE WON'T BE INTIMIDATED
AFTER DAYS OF NEGOTIATIONS WITH
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
PROFESSOR CHRISTINE FORD HAS NOW
AGREED TO TESTIFY ABOUT THE
ALLEGATIONS SHE MADE AGAINST
JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
LET ME BE PERFECTLY CLEAR.
THESE ARE MYSTERIOUS ALLEGATION
ALLEGATIONS, -- SERIOUS
ALLEGATIONS, I SAID IT MANY
TIMES.
PROFESSOR FORD DESERVES TO BE
HEARD AND THOSE ALLEGATIONS
SHOULD BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
THIS COMING THURSDAY, YOU THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE TO
HEAR FROM BOTH PROFESSOR FORD
AND JUDGE KAVANAUGH IN AN OPEN
SETTING.
CHAIRMAN GRASSLEY OF THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WAS RIGHT TO
HOLD THE HEARING, AND THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN AND ARE
BEING EXTREMELY FAIR AND
ACCOMMODATING AND TAKING THESE
BUT TONIGHT WE NEED TO    TO A S
BUT TONIGHT WE NEED TO    TO A E
ALLEGATIONS SERIOUSLY.
BUT TONIGHT WE NEED TO    TO A P
BACK AND REMEMBER WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT HERE.
THESE ARE 35-YEAR-OLD
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT ALLEGATIONS
MADE BY PROFESSIONAL OR FORWARD
IT TO CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS.
THE CLAIMS DATE BACK TO WHEN
FORD AND KAVANAUGH WERE IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN, SHE
WAS AWARE OF PROFESSOR FORD'S
ALLEGATIONS SINCE JULY.
SHE SAT ON THEM AND KEPT IN THE
SECRET.
UNTIL AFTER CAVANAUGH AND
KAVANAUGH'S A PUBLIC HEARING
LENGTHY MEETINGS WITH JUDGE
KAVANAUGH.
IN FACT, DIANNE FEINSTEIN
REFUSED TO CONSENT REPUBLICANS,
OR COLLEAGUES, THE FULL
UNREDACTED LETTER WHERE
ACCUSATIONS WERE FIRST MADE BACK
IN JULY UNTIL TODAY.
NOW PROFESSOR FORD CANNOT
REMEMBER THE DATE OR LOCATION OF
THE ALLEGED INCIDENT.
THE FOUR WITNESSES THAT FORD
HERSELF LISTED TO CORROBORATE
HER CLAIMS, THEY ARE ALL NOW ON
RECORD DENYING WHAT FORD IS
ALLEGING.
JUDGE KAVANAUGH SAT DOWN WITH
OUR OWN MARTHA MacCALLUM AND
CATEGORICALLY REFUTED THESE
CLAIMS ONCE AGAIN.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> Judge Kavanaugh: I MAY HAVE
MET HER, WE DID NOT TRAVEL IN
THE SAME SOCIAL CIRCLES.
SHE WAS NOT A FRIEND OR SOMEONE
I KNEW.
>> Martha: IF YOU DON'T
REMEMBER BEING AT PARTIES WITH
HER EVER?
>> Judge Kavanaugh: I DO NOT.
THIS IS AN ALLEGATION ABOUT A
PARTY IN THE SUMMER OF 1982 AT A
HOUSE ON CONNECTICUT AVENUE ON
EAST WEST HIGHWAY WITH FIVE
PEOPLE PRESENT.
I WAS NEVER AT ANY SUCH PARTY.
THE OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE ALLEGED
TO BE PRESENT SAID THEY DON'T
REMEMBER ANY SUCH PARTY.
A WOMAN WHO WAS PRESENT, OF
ANOTHER WOMAN WHO WAS PRESENT
WHO IS DR. FORD'S LIFELONG
FRIEND HAS SAID SHE DOESN'T KNOW
ME, AND NEVER REMEMBERS BEING AT
A PARTY WITH ME AT ANY TIME IN
HER LIFE.
>> Sean: NOW KAVANAUGH IS
FACING ONE MORE ALLEGATION
BECAUSE OVER THE WEEKEND, THE
NEW YORKER BROUGHT UP ANOTHER
DECADES-OLD CLAIM AGAINST AND
KAVANAUGH, IN THIS CASE A WOMAN
NAMED DEBORAH RAMIREZ.
SHE IS CLAIMING THAT IN THE
1980s WHEN HE WAS IN COLLEGE,
THAT KAVANAUGH EXPOSED HIMSELF
TO HER AT A DRUNKEN COLLEGE
PARTY AT YALE UNIVERSITY.
RAMIREZ HERSELF WASN'T TOTALLY
SURE IF KAVANAUGH WAS A
PERPETRATOR.
SHE BECAME "QUICKLY INEBRIATED"
AT THE PARTY, HER WORDS.
SHE TOLD THE NEW YORKER THAT SHE
WASN'T "FOGGY AND SLURRING HER
WORDS."
SHE EVEN ACKNOWLEDGES SHE HAD
SIGNIFICANT MEMORY GAP FROM THAT
EVENING.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" SPENT OVER
A WEEK TRYING TO CORROBORATE HER
STORY, TALKING TO DOZENS OF
PEOPLE, AND OF THE TIME SAID
THIS, "THEY HAVE INTERVIEWED
SEVERAL DOZEN PEOPLE OVER THE
PAST WEEK IN AN ATTEMPT TO
CORROBORATE HER STORY.
THEY COULD FIND NO ONE WITH
FIRSTHAND KNOWLEDGE.
MS. RAMIREZ HERSELF CONTACTED
FORMER YALE CLASSMATES ASKING IF
THEY RECALL THE INCIDENT AND
TOLD SOME OF THEM THAT SHE COULD
NOT BE CERTAIN THAT
MR. KAVANAUGH WAS THE ONE WHO
EXPOSED HIMSELF.
AND THOSE WHO REMARRY IS LISTED
AS WITNESSES IN YET ANOTHER CASE
HERE, WELCOME TO THE INDECENT
CHARGES?
THEY ARE ALL FLATLY DENYING.
IF THE INCIDENT DEBBIE ALLEGES
EVER OCCURRED, WE WOULD HAVE
SEEN OR HEARD ABOUT IT.
BUT WE HAVE NOT.
THE BEHAVIOR SHE DESCRIBES WOULD
BE COMPLETELY OUT OF CHARACTER
FOR BRETT.
IN ADDITION, SOME OF US KNEW
DEBBIE LONG AFTER YALE AND SHE
NEVER DESCRIBES THIS INCIDENT
UNTIL HIS SUPREME COURT
NOMINATION WAS PENDING.
THE NEW YORKER ALSO INTERVIEWED
RAMIREZ'S BEST FRIEND AT THE
TIME OF THE ALLEGED INCIDENT AND
SHE'S ALSO DENYING ANY KNOWLEDGE
OF THE CLAIMS.
AND SHE SAID IT "THIS WAS A
WOMAN KNOWS BEST FRIEND WITH, WE
SHARED INTIMATE DETAILS OF HER,
OUR LIVES.
I WAS NEVER TOLD THE STORY BY
HER OR ANYONE ELSE.
I NEVER SAW IT OR HEARD OF IT
HAPPENING."
JUDGE KAVANAUGH ALSO DENIED
EMPHATICALLY THESE DECADE-OLD
CHARGES.
IN A STATEMENT HE WROTE "THESE
ARE SMEARS, PURE AND SIMPLE AND
THEY DEBASE OUR PUBLIC
DISCOURSE.
BUT THEY ARE ALSO A THREAT TO
ANY MAN OR WOMAN WHO WISHES TO
SERVE OUR COUNTRY.
SUCH GROTESQUE AND OBVIOUS
CHARACTER ASSASSINATIONS, IF
ALLOWED TO SUCCEED, IT WILL
DISSUADE COMPETENT AND GOOD
PEOPLE OF ALL POLITICAL
PERSUASIONS FROM SERVICE.
AS I TOLD THE COMMITTEE DURING
THE HEARING, A FEDERAL JUDGE
MUST BE INDEPENDENT, NOT SWAYED
BY PUBLIC OR POLITICAL PRESSURE.
THAT'S A KIND OF JUDGE I WOULD
ALWAYS BE AND AND AT THE
VIOLENCE AGAINST MY FAMILY WOULD
NOT DRIVE THEM OUT.
KAVANAUGH DENIED THESE CHARGES
IN HIS INTERVIEW WITH MARTHA.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> Judge Kavanaugh: I NEVER
DID ANY SUCH THING.
THE OTHER PEOPLE ALLEGED TO BE
THERE DON'T RECALL ANY SUCH
THING.
IF SUCH A THING HAD HAPPENED, IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN THE TALK OF
CAMPUS.
THE WOMEN I KNEW IN COLLEGE, AND
THE MEN I KNEW IN COLLEGE THAT
IT'S INCONCEIVABLE THAT I COULD
HAVE DONE SUCH A THING, AND
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAS
REPORTED THAT JUST LAST WEEK THE
PERSON MAKING THE ACCUSATION WAS
CALLING OTHER CLASSMATES, SAYING
SHE WAS NOT SURE THAT AND I HAD
DONE THIS.
AGAIN, JUST ASKING FOR A FAIR
PROCESS WHERE I CAN BE HEARD AND
I CAN DEFEND MY INTEGRITY.
>> Sean: DURING THIS INTERVIEW
HE TOOK IT EVEN A STEP FURTHER.
WATCH THIS.
>> Judge Kavanaugh: PEOPLE
GENERALLY IN HIGH SCHOOL, I
THINK ALL OF US HAVE LOOKED BACK
ON THINGS AND REGRETTED OR
CRINGED A BIT.
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT AN
ALLEGATION OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
I NEVER SEXUALLY ASSAULTED
ANYONE.
I NEVER HAVE DONE ANYTHING LIKE
THAT.
>> Martha: SO ALL THESE YEARS
IN QUESTION, YOU ARE A?
>> Judge Kavanaugh: THAT'S
CORRECT.
>> Martha: YOU NEVER HAD
INTERCOURSE WITH ANYONE IN
HIGH SCHOOL?
>> Judge Kavanaugh: AND MANY
YEARS AFTER.
>> Sean: THEN HE WENT ON TO
DEFEND HIS CHARACTER IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
>> Martha: WAS THERE EVER A
TIME YOU DRINK SO MUCH SHE
COULDN'T REMEMBER THE NIGHT
BEFORE?
>>
WOMEN BEING TAKEN INTO ROOMS AND
OR HAVING WITH A NUMBER OF MEN,
CONSENSUAL OR OTHERWISE, WAS NOT
GOING ON AT THE PARTY'S ERRATIC?
>> Judge Kavanaugh: I NEVER
SAW ANY SUCH THING.
I CERTAINLY NEVER PARTICIPATED
IN ANY SUCH THING BUT I NEVER
SAW OR HEARD OF ANY SUCH THING.
I WAS FOCUSED ON TRYING TO BE
NUMBER ONE IN MY CLASS AND BEING
CAPTAIN OF THE VARSITY
BASKETBALL TEAM, AND IT DURING
MY SERVICE PROJECTS, AND GOING
TO CHURCH.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE TIME I
SPENT IN HIGH SCHOOL WAS
STUDYING, OR FOCUSED ON SPORTS
AND BEING A GOOD FRIEND TO THE
BOYS AND THE GIRLS THAT I WAS
FRIENDS WITH.
WE HAVE THESE GREAT LIFELONG
FRIENDSHIPS.
>> Sean: DESPITE ALL THESE
CHARGES, JUDGE KAVANAUGH SAYS HE
WILL NOT BE QUIET AND HE'S
VOWING NOT TO BE INTIMIDATED
INTO WITHDRAWING HIS NOMINATION.
WHILE JUDGE KAVANAUGH IS
STANDING FIRM, RIGHTLY DEMANDING
A FAIR PROCESS, IT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THE TOLD
THAT IT ALSO TAKES ON A FAMILY.
AGAIN, WHERE IS THE PRESUMPTION
OF INNOCENCE?
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO HAVE
THESE CONVERSATIONS, AND THEY
KNOW BRETT AND THEY KNOW, WE
TOLD HIM AT THE VERY BEGINNING
OF THIS PROCESS THAT IT'S NOT
FUN SOMETIMES.
HE WILL HEAR THINGS THAT PEOPLE
FEEL STRONGLY, AND JUST
REMEMBER, YOU KNOW YOUR DAD.
>> Sean: NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS STANDING BY HIS NOMINEE AND
PREDICTED HER EARLIER TONIGHT
THAT HE WILL BE CONFIRMED.
LOOK AT THIS.
>> IT WILL BE SAD INDEED IF
SOMETHING HAPPENS TO REROUTE
THAT.
THIS IS A FINE MAN AND CERTAINLY
HOPE HE'S GOING TO BE CONFIRMED
AND QUICKLY.
HIS FAMILY HAS SUFFERED.
WHAT IS GOING ON IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD HAPPEN.
BRETT KAVANAUGH IS AN ABSOLUTE
OUTSTANDING PERSON AND
HOPEFULLY, HE WILL BE CONFIRMED
QUICKLY.
>> Sean: THIS ALL COMES AS ONE
FALLS RUMOR HAS BEEN DEBUNKED.
MAINSTREAM MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS
WERE GLEEFULLY SPREADING A RUMOR
THAT FEMALE STUDENTS WERE
COACHED BY A LAW PROFESSOR ON
HOW TO DRESS IN AN OUTGOING WAY
WHEN THEY WERE INTERVIEWING WITH
JUDGE KAVANAUGH, A RUMOR THAT
THE PROFESSOR HAS COMPLETELY
DENIED.
AT IN SPITE OF EVERYTHING WE
JUST SHOWED YOU, THEIR PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY THAT SHOULD NOT BE
POLITICAL.
DEMOCRATS, PEOPLE ON THE LEFT,
THEY HAVE ALREADY CONVICTED
JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
ACCORDING TO THEM HE HAS KNOWN
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE AND NO
RIGHT TO BE HEARD, NO REASON TO
BE BELIEVED, NO DUE PROCESS.
ACTUALLY, THERE WERE LAWMAKERS,
LAWMAKERS THAT WERE THROWING LAW
OUT THE WINDOW AND CLAIMING HIS
GUILT BY ACCUSATION.
THIS SHOULD NOT HAPPEN IN THIS
COUNTRY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE SENATE SHOULDN'T RELY ON
TO CONFLICTING ACCOUNTS AND
DECIDE, WE ARE OKAY WITH NOT
KNOWING, WE ARE OKAY WITH THE
FACT THAT WE MIGHT BE PUTTING
SOMEONE WHO COMMITTED ATTEMPTED
RAPE.
>> I BELIEVE HER.
ANYONE WHO COMES FORWARD AT THIS
POINT TO BE PREPARED TO TESTIFY
IN THE UNITED STATES SENATE
AGAINST SOMEONE WHO IS BEING
NOMINATED TO ONE OF THE MOST
POWERFUL POSITIONS IN THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT, THAT
TAKES AN EXTRA ORDINARY AMOUNT
OF COURAGE.
>> NOT ONLY DO WOMEN LIKE
DR. FORD WHO BRAVELY COME
FORWARD NEED TO BE HER TO COME
UP BUT THEY NEED TO BE BELIEVED.
THEY NEED TO BE BELIEVED.
>> I WANT TO SAY TO THE MEN OF
THIS COUNTRY, SHUT UP AND STEP
UP, DO THE RIGHT THING.
>> LET ME SAY RIGHT AT THE
OUTSET, I BELIEVE DR. FORD.
I BELIEVE THE SURVIVOR HERE.
THERE'S EVERY REASON TO BELIEVE
HER.
SHE HAS COME FORWARD
COURAGEOUSLY AND BRAVELY.
>> I BELIEVE WITH HER AND I
STAND WITH HER.
>> SO IF SHE SHOWS UP ON
MONDAY -- >> I DON'T THINK SHE
SHOULD BE BULLIED INTO THE
SCENARIO, IT'S A SHAM HEARING
AND I DON'T THINK SHE SHOULD
PARTICIPATE IN IT.
>> I BELIEVE PROFESSOR FORD.
I THINK SHE'S CREDIBLE AND I
THINK WHEN THE INVESTIGATION IS
FINISHED AND WHEN SHE TESTIFIES
AND WHEN JUDGE KAVANAUGH
TESTIFIES, I THINK A MAJORITY OF
SENATORS WILL FIND HER CREDIBLE.
AND I DON'T THINK -- I NEVER
THOUGHT JUDGE KAVANAUGH SHOULD
GET APPOINTED.
>> NO PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
>> AT THE VERY SAME TIME, ALL
THE PEOPLE YOU ARE WATCHING
HERE, WE HAVE A CASE NOT 36 OR
SEVEN OR FIVE YEARS AGO, BUT
KEITH ELLISON, THE NUMBER TWO
GUY AT THE DNC HAS BEEN ACCUSED
OF REPEATED PHYSICAL AND
EMOTIONAL ABUSE AND THE DNC HAS
SMEARED AND SLANDERED AND
IGNORED THE PERSON MAKING THAT
ALLEGATION.
THAT WAS BACK IN AUGUST.
THIS YEAR.
SO WHAT YOU ARE WATCHING IS A
DEMOCRATIC PARTY PLAYING
POLITICS, SADLY EXPLOITING A
CONDUCT ALLEGATION ACCUSATION,
THAT'S IT, FOR POLITICAL GAIN.
JUMPING TO CONCLUSIONS AND
RUSHING TO JUDGMENT.
THESE ARE SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS.
BUT TONIGHT EVERY AMERICAN,
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRAT,
CONSERVATIVE AND LIBERAL.
THIS IS WHY YOU NEED A HEALTHY
DOSE OF SKEPTICISM.
LET ME TELL YOU WHY.
DEBORAH KATZ HAS VIEWS ON
SEXUAL ASSAULT THAT HAVE BEEN
EXTRAORDINARY POLITICAL AND
INCONSISTENT AT BEST.
FOR EXAMPLE, SHE SAID THIS ABOUT
PAULA JONES.
NOBODY IN THE MEDIA REPORTS IT.
PAULA JONES' SUIT IS VERY, VERY
WEAK AND, NOT BY HER OWN
TESTIMONY HAD LASTED TEN OR
12 MINUTES.
SHE SUFFERED NO REPERCUSSIONS IN
THE WORKPLACE.
SHE SAID, CLEARLY A ONE-TIME
INCIDENT THAT TOOK PLACE IN
10-12 MINUTES, SHE LEFT OF HER
OWN VOLITION, AND THE COURTS ARE
FINDING THAT WAS NOT ENOUGH TO
CREATE A HOSTILE WORK
ENVIRONMENT CLAIM.
SHE ALSO SET OF CREEPY
SENATOR AL FRANKEN "CONTEXT IS
RELEVANT.
HE DID NOT DO THIS AS A MEMBER
THE U.S. SENATE."
YES HE DID.
AND BY THE WAY HE DID THIS IN
THE CAPACITY OF SOMEONE WHO IS
STILL FUNCTIONING AS AN
ENTERTAINER.
CLEARLY, PROFESSOR FORD'S
ATTORNEY HAS A LEFT-WING RADICAL
INCONSISTENT POLITICAL AGENDA,
AND "THE DAILY CALLER" EVEN
UNCOVERED BACK IN 2017.
AND WE HAVE THE TAPE.
HERE IT IS.
>> FINALLY OVER THE FINISH LINE
COME UP WITH A GENERAL GRATEFUL
TO THE COLLEAGUES WHO WENT FOR
HIM.
>> I CAN'T APPRECIATE, EXPRESS
HOW APPRECIATIVE I AM FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO STOOD BY ME DURING
THESE DIFFICULT TIMES.
>> IT WAS A A BITTER FEUD TO THE
VERY END.
>> GOING TO FIGHT BACK, GOING TO
RESIST.
WE ARE ALSO LEARNING THAT
PROFESSOR FORD IS ADDING ANOTHER
PERSON TO HIS LEGAL TEAM, AN
ATTORNEY NAMED MICHAEL BROMWICH.
HE'S THE LAWYER REPRESENTING
FIRED FBI DIRECTOR ANDREW
McCABE.
THIS BRINGS US TO OUR HANNITY
HISTORY LESSON SURROUNDING THE
DEMOCRATIC PLAYBOOK.
EVERY ELECTION CYCLE, AND THEY
ARE LITERALLY NAMING THE
CHARACTER OF THE POLITICAL
OPPONENTS, EVEN IF IT MEANS
LYING IN THE PROCESS.
THEY DEMONIZE ALL CONSERVATIVES.
THERE'S NOT A CONSERVATIVE THAT
I KNOW THAT HAS NOT BEEN THROUGH
THIS.
IN FACT EVERY FOUR YEARS, EVERY
TWO YEARS, REPUBLICANS ARE
RACIST, MISOGYNISTIC,
HOMOPHOBIC, ISLAMOPHOBIC.
THEY WANT DIRTY AIR AND WATER,
THEY WANT TO KILL YOUR CHILDREN
AND THROW GRANNY OVER A CLIFF.
THE LEFT HAS ALSO RUSHED TO
JUDGMENT IN THE WAKE OF OTHER
MAJOR EVENTS.
THEY HAVE BEEN WRONG.
ON THIS PROGRAM THEY'VE BEEN
RIGHT.
WE DIDN'T RUSH TO JUDGMENT IN
THE DUKE LACROSSE CASE.
REMEMBER THE SUMMER OLYMPICS AND
BOMBING?
REMEMBER BECAUSE HE SAID HE FIT
THE PROFILE OF A LOAN BOMBER,
BECAUSE HE LIVED WITH HIS MOTHE
MOTHER.
RICHARD JULES LISTENING TO MY
RADIO SHOW WAS A LOCALHOST IN
ATLANTA AT THE TIME.
HE MUST THINK ME FOR BEING THE
ONLY ONE NOT TO RUSH TO JUDGMEN
JUDGMENT.
REMEMBER THE RUSH TO JUDGMENT IN
BALTIMORE, WITH FREDDIE GRAY?
NEVER WHEN OBAMA SAID THE
CAMBRIDGE BELIEF ACTED STUPIDLY?
WE HAVE ON THIS PROGRAM ADOPTED
THE "WE WILL NOT RUSH TO
JUDGMENT.
WE WILL WAIT AND WE WILL SEE."
ON THE DUKE LACROSSE KIDS I WENT
TO MEET WITH THEIR PARENTS AND I
MET WAS GEORGE ZIMMERMAN'S
ATTORNEY AND THAT GEORGE
ZIMMERMAN AND ASKED HIM TOUGH
QUESTIONS.
YOU SEE HAD NOW COME EVERY TIME
THERE IS A SUPREME COURT
NOMINEE, AND THAT'S THE
REPUBLICAN APPOINTS HIM.
WE WE SOUGHT JUDGE BORK, AND
MITT ROMNEY WAS SEXIST.
HE HAD BINDERS FULL OF WOMEN'S
RESUMES.
REMEMBER THEY TURN HIS EFFORTS
TO HIRE WOMEN INTO AN ATTACK
ABOUT HIM BEING SEXIST.
MITT ROMNEY WAS NOT.
WHENEVER THEY HAD FALSELY
ACCUSED HIM, REMEMBER HARRY REI
HARRY REID, AND HE HAD NO REAL
REGRETS ABOUT SPENDING THOSE
LIES AND FALSE ATTACKS.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS.
THIS IS WHY AMERICAN DUTIES HAVE
A DUTY TO SKEPTICAL.
WE SEE IT EVERY TWO YEARS, EVERY
FOUR YEARS, EVERY SUPREME COURT
NOMINEE AND EVERY BIG
HIGH-PROFILE CASE THAT THEY
POLITICIZE.
HERE'S A LOOK AT HAIRY REDA.
>> LET HIM PROVE THAT HE HAS
PAID TAXES, BECAUSE HE HASN'T.
I DON'T REGRET THAT AT ALL.
NO ONE WOULD HELP ME, SO I DID
IT ON MY OWN.
>> NO REGRETS ABOUT ROMNEY OR
THE COAT BROTHERS.
>> I REGRET TELLING A TOTAL LIE
AND SMEARING SOMEBODY.
FROM MITT ROMNEY TO ROBERT BORK
TO CLARENCE THOMAS TO
GEORGE BUSH, FRANKLY EVERY A
CONSERVATIVE I KNOW, I WAS BEEN
FORCED TO DEAL WITH THEIR LIFE
AND SOME OF THESE BASELESS
CHARACTER SMEARS AND CHARACTER
ASSASSINATIONS.
THAT IS TO CALL REPUBLICANS
RACIST AND IT HAPPENS EVERY
REPUBLICAN SEASON.
>> MANY REPUBLICANS TALK IN
CODED RACIAL LANGUAGE ABOUT
TAKERS AND LOSERS.
THEY DEMONIZE AT PRESIDENT OBAMA
AND ENCOURAGE THE UGLIEST
IMPULSES OF THE PARANOID FRENCH.
>> YOU EXPECT THE SUPPORT OF
PRESIDENT  , YOU WILL ACCEPT THE
CLAN SYMPATHIZERS BEFORE YOU ARE
PRESIDENT  , YOU WILL ACCEPT THR
SUPPORT AFTER THEY ARE
PRESIDENT?
>> HE WILL LET THEM WRITE THEIR
OWN RULES.
UNCHAINED WALL STREET.
THEY WILL PUT YOU ALL BACK IN
CHAINS.
>> IT'S WRONG WHAT THE LEADER OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AND THIS
CONGRESS ARE DOING AND BLOCKING
AN ACCURATE CENSUS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO COUNT EVERYONE
THAT THEY DON'T THINK THEY CAN
COUNT ON.
>> THEY ARE IN FAVOR OF
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION, IF YOU CAN
DUNK THE BASKETBALL OR A SINK A
THREE-POINT SHOT.
BUT THEY ARE NOT IN FAVOR OF IT
IF YOU MERELY HAVE THE POTENTIAL
TO BE A LEADER IN YOUR COMMUNITY
AND BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER.
DON'T TELL ME WE HAVE A
COLOR-BLIND SOCIETY.
>> 2-7, WHEN
GOVERNOR GEORGE W. BUSH REFUSED
TO SUPPORT HATE CRIMES
LEGISLATION, IT WAS LIKE MY
FATHER WAS KILLED ALL OVER
AGAIN.
>> WHEN YOU DON'T VOTE, YOU LET
ANOTHER CHURCH EXPLODE.
WHEN YOU DON'T VOTE, YOU ALLOW
ANOTHER CROSS TO BURN.
>> REAL SMEARS, REAL CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION, AND IT HAPPENS
PREDICTABLY EVERY ELECTION
SEASON AND IT HAPPENS WITH
SUPREME COURT NOMINEES.
THIS IS A GUTTER POLITICS AT ITS
WORST AND SADLY, WE ARE GOING TO
SEE MORE AND MORE OF THESE
TACTICS AS WE NOW MARCH 43 DAYS
OR SO TOWARDS THE MIDTERMS.
WE WILL HAVE A LOT MORE ON THIS
IN A MOMENT, BUT FIRST BREAKING
TODAY IT ALSO APPEARS THAT THE
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD
ROSENSTEIN IS HANGING ONTO HIS
JOB, AT LEAST FOR NOW.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ISSUED ON
REPORT ACCUSING ROD ROSENSTEIN,
AND THEY ARE STICKING BY IT, OF
PLOTTING TO RALLY CABINET
OFFICIALS AND INVOKED THE 25TH
AMENDMENT.